♪
(Karen)
Margaret, thank you
for welcoming us
on this fantastic research
vessel, the Melville.
My pleasure.
I want to ask you about
something I heard about.
You recently were in Paris
last year
and took a team of
students and researchers
from the Scripps Institution
of Oceanography.
How was the conference and what
were you trying to accomplish?
I wasn't in Paris
for shopping.
I was there for the Conference
of the Parties, COP 21.
This is the place where the
climate negotiations take place.
We have been the head
of the UC delegation
for as long as we've been
parties to the conference,
and we are involved with this
because of our long-term
research on climate.
So Scripps Institution
of Oceanography
has been one
of the premier institutions
in detecting climate change
and being able to attribute
climate change
to the various causes,
how much are we
responsible for,
how much is happening
as a result of natural change,
and also we've been very
involved in modeling climate
to be able tell
what will happen
as a result of increasing
greenhouse gases.
It's only natural
that we would go.
We really had three focuses
of attention for this meeting.
The first was that although
the oceans are 70% of the globe,
the oceans
were not even included
in the climate negotiations.
Yes. I hope everyone
can see your eyes.
Startling.
Yes.
And that was really
because the primary focus
had been on
what was happening on land
and what the impacts were
on land.
But over the 21 years
that we've been negotiating,
we've found profound impacts
on the ocean.
The ocean is becoming warmer.
We have five decades of data
that shows how much warmer
the ocean is.
It's actually taking up
90% of the heat.
The second is
that many people
have heard of
ocean acidification,
the ocean becoming
slightly more acidic.
That's also a result
of the CO2.
CO2 is dissolving
in the oceans.
And then
the third thing is that,
as a result of both warming
and the ocean acidification
and other changes,
the oxygen content
in the mid-waters of the ocean
is decreasing.
So as we say,
the ocean is becoming hot,
more sour, and breathless.
We wanted
to call attention to this,
the fact that oceans
have to be included.
I'm pleased to say
that they are.
We were successful with others
who were focused on this.
We also were focused on other
parts of the climate system.
For example, although
we talk a lot about CO2,
there are lots of other gases
that contribute to warming.
Some of them are methane,
even all the particulate soot
that comes from burning forests
and coal and so forth
contributes to that.
So we also wanted
to remind everybody
to be conscious of those factors
as well as CO2.
Is Scripps
and the United States
really pushing then
this awareness
and the need
to educate people
about the environmental
health of our oceans?
Absolutely,
and this is a big focus
of the U.S. role
in the negotiations
and, of course,
of Scripps Oceanography's role.
It must have been an amazing
experience for students
that went to
this conference in Paris.
Yes, and all
of the graduate students
had a chance to speak
in one of the side sessions.
We also had
an informational booth
to tell people about
what was happening
and to provide
more information.
The students
helped us man the booth.
So I want to know about
how people find
their passions in life.
Clearly, you have a passion
for ocean science
and environmental health.
I know you went to
the University of Illinois
and did undergraduate work
in geology.
That's right.
So tell me,
from geology, when did you get
interested about the oceans?
It really was through geology.
I never lived near the ocean,
and I'd only seen the ocean once
when I graduated from college.
But many of the rocks that
I studied formed in the oceans,
and as long as they were
talking about rocks
that formed on beaches
or rivers or close to land,
that they had really great
models of what was happening
and when they said things
that made sense.
When they started talking about
rocks from the deep ocean,
there was
a lot of hand waving,
and it seemed that what I should
do is study oceanography,
then I'd bring all that
knowledge back to geology.
But although
I'm a geological oceanographer
and study geologic processes
in the ocean,
I never went back
to land geology.
I heard the name paleo--
paleontology
and oceanography blended.
Paleoceanography,
the study of the oceans
in the past
and how they evolved,
what was happening in them.
And that also led me
to paleoclimate,
what was happening
in the climate
and how that
affected the ocean.
That's how I got interested
in climate change.
And your PHD was done
in Rhode Island, correct?
Did you spend time on a ship
like this for your research?
Absolutely.
What was that like?
I have to ask.
How many other women
were in the field with you
studying oceanography
or marine science
in graduate school,
and how many other women
were on a research vessel
taking measurements
of the ocean?
I was very fortunate.
I started my graduate work
at Oregon State University,
and my first cruise was
two months after I arrived.
There were three women
on the cruise.
We were all graduate students.
There weren't any female faculty
in geological oceanography.
So I really had companions,
female companions on the ships.
And my second cruise
was the next summer,
and that was
in the Atlantic Ocean.
There were other
female graduate students,
most notably Kathy Sullivan,
who is now
the administrator of NOAA.
That was her first
oceanographic cruise,
my second.
And we still are
very close friends.
It often happens, the people
you are graduate students with
become your friends
and colleagues for life.
Do you know the current data?
My background is physics,
and it's come a long way
since I went to school.
Still physics, computer
science, and engineering
are highly underrepresented
with females--
eighteen, nineteen percent
females getting
bachelor's of science
degrees in those subjects.
What about marine science
and oceanography?
It depends on
the field of oceanography.
So in biological oceanography
and marine biology,
half of our entering class
of graduate students
have been women for some time.
In physical oceanography,
the circulation of the oceans
and currents and so forth,
the percentage is less,
as it is in geological
oceanography or geophysics.
So there are many more women
entering the field now
and entering study
of oceanography
than there ever
have been before.
But still, there's some
differences amongst the fields.
Right.
You've also spent your career as
a researcher and administrator.
Have you noticed a difference
in your female colleagues
as you've changed from
the research environment
to the administrative
environment?
I think that I was really
in the first wave.
Right.
And so now, as I said,
Kathy Sullivan,
who was a graduate student
at the same time,
is the administrator of NOAA.
Another person that was
a graduate at the same time,
Marcia McNutt, is the editor
of Science magazine.
Some other people that I went
to graduate school with
are senior administrators
in the U.S. Geological Survey.
One of them is a dean at
University of Texas, Austin.
So now there are
quite a few women
who have not only
been doing research
and have been very successful,
but are also administrators.
So you were with women
that were trailblazers
for the women to come,
which is very exciting.
As director of Scripps
Institution of Oceanography,
you'll be welcoming a new
vessel into the fleet soon.
Can you talk
about that vessel
and how different it is
than the Melville
and what the plans are
for that vessel?
Our new vessel
is the R/V Sally Ride,
and it is a 248-foot vessel,
50 feet wide.
It will have space for
24 scientists to be on board
and 20 crew.
And this ship was paid for
by the Office of Naval Research
and the Navy,
Department of Defense.
The new ship is built
by a shipyard in Washington,
but under the supervision
of both Scripps and Navy.
So it's a partnership
between Scripps and the Navy.
And it is part of a new class
of oceanographic ships
that are all named
after astronauts.
And we're so delighted that
this one is named Sally Ride
because, of course,
Sally is from this community
in San Diego.
She was a PhD in physics,
and when she finished
her very distinguished career
as an astronaut,
she came back to University
of California, San Diego,
as a physics professor.
So this is really an honor
for us to have the Sally Ride,
and it's so appropriate
for this community
to share that distinction.
Sally was the first female
astronaut from our country.
Her maiden voyage in space
was in 1983.
I was a grad student
at that time
in a field that was very
underrepresented with women.
I never aspired
to be an astronaut,
but when that happened,
I realized that she's opened--
paved the way for women to
believe they could do anything.
Where were you when she
first launched into space?
I had a similar experience.
I was a junior faculty member
at University of Rhode Island,
and it happened that
all of my graduate students
and my technicians were women,
and we used to celebrate
everything.
We celebrated when we got
a scientific paper published.
We celebrated
when we got funding.
We celebrated birthdays.
The way that we celebrated
was we would drink champagne,
and we would take the little
metal container for the cork
and put the cork in it
with a little label.
We had acoustic tile ceilings,
and we would
put the cork up there,
commemorating what happened.
And the day that
that launch took place,
one of my technicians brought in
a portable television,
and we all watched it on TV.
We drank champagne,
and we put a little tag on
that champagne cork that said,
"Sally Ride
was representing us all."
Wow.
They were in that lab
for a long time after I left.
I like to say she broke
the ultimate glass ceiling.
Exactly.
Naming the research vessel
after her,
it's one of the most
fitting honors.
After her death, she was awarded
the Presidential Freedom Medal,
but I think,
if she was alive today,
knowing that there was an
exploration ship going out,
and she was a believer
of making sure
all students were
STEM literate--
Yes.
I'm sure you have
the same beliefs.
People should be aware
of what's going on
in our oceans,
in our environment,
so it's our duty as educators
to provide that knowledge.
Right, and we're very dedicated
to students participating,
so I can't think of a cruise
that doesn't have
graduate students
as part of the scientific crew.
They're really responsible,
very responsible,
for tremendously expensive
and complicated equipment
that they bring on board
and deploy.
We even have whole cruises
that are just student cruises,
and we have funding
from the state of California
that's available to all of the
UCs for students to participate
and to propose to do
research on the ships.
We've even had them meet
the ship in foreign ports
and do research
in the Indian Ocean.
A group proposed
to use the ship
in the western Pacific Ocean
this next year,
so it's very much a research
experience for our students
and for all of the students
that participate.
You've been director at Scripps
for two or three years?
Two and a half years.
Do you have have plans,
say, a five-year plan?
Well, it's not my plan.
It's Scripps' plan.
About a year and a half ago,
all the faculty and researchers
went off on a retreat
for a day and a half
to talk about, not so much
every little thing that we do,
but the big ideas,
the ones that require
a whole group of people
and that would really
require the institution
to get behind the idea
as well as just
the individual researchers.
We have a whole group
of those ideas.
Some of the highlights are
certainly related to climate,
the impact of climate
on the oceans, on us, on land,
how we can adapt to that.
We're also very interested
in hazards like tsunamis
and earthquakes and drought
and flood
and how our research
can help people
be more resilient
in the face of hazards.
We're world experts in the
development of new technology,
whether it's measurement devices
or whole platforms of equipment
or even systems of observation.
And so that will certainly be
a continuing area of effort.
And then we're also
very interested
in human health
and the oceans.
How does the ocean affect
our health?
Whether it's pollution,
whether it's seafood safety,
whether it's the sea spray
that affects our health.
Are there drugs from the ocean
that we can develop
that will help us with
any kind of health problem?
Those are a few of the exciting
areas the faculty identified
that we'll be working on.
Most of them require
the use of the ship.
Right, right.
We talked about Paris and
your team educating people
not only about the atmosphere
with increased carbon emissions,
but also the oceans.
You said that there has been
change in the mindset now,
and people understand that
ocean health is important.
Do you think young people,
during your career,
that this current
generation of young people
are more aware
of the environment
and are more concerned with
protecting the environment
and taking care of our planet
for the future?
Definitely.
When I was growing up,
people were interested
in the ocean,
and people my age, as a young
student, were interested,
but it was really
more curiosity.
What's out there?
How does it work?
How can we get
to understand it?
Now that we do
understand more,
we see a lot of the ways
that humans impact the ocean,
in spite of it being so big.
I think one of the sort of
strange things is
when you look at the ocean
from land or ship,
it looks the same
as it always has.
Beautiful blue water.
And one of the things
about the ocean is, of course,
most of the life of the ocean
is underneath,
so we don't see it changing.
The chemistry of the ocean
is not something you see.
The currents are not
something that you see.
The temperature
is not something that you see.
But now I think
that we've done a better job
of conveying to people
what's actually happening.
There's a lot of interest in how
is this going to influence us
and what do we need to do
to adapt to the changes,
what do we need to do to protect
the ocean from greater change,
and are there other changes
that we don't know about
that are happening.
Is there anything that you feel
like you haven't accomplished?
You've done so much
through your research,
through your time at
National Science Foundation,
now ending up
here at Scripps,
you been in research vessels,
you've been around the world.
Is there anything you feel
you need to do in your career?
You always feel
like you need to do this.
One of the exciting things,
especially for this community
in San Diego,
is what a rich community it is
for the maritime economy.
That is something that we're
looking at at Scripps,
and how can we partner
more effectively
with all of the companies
that are developing technologies
and capability with,
for the ocean.
A lot of people are interested
in biotech and the ocean.
How can we partner with them?
So there are always
new frontiers
and new capabilities
and new excitement.
There is not a single day that
I go into the office and say,
"Oh, ho-hum.
It's another day at the office."
It's a really exciting time.
Thank you, Margaret,
for your time,
your inspiration,
and for being a lifetime
leader in ocean science.
Thank you.
We look forward
to welcoming the community
to visit the Sally Ride
this summer.
Thank you.
Funding to purchase and make
this educational production
accessible was provided by the
U.S. Department of Education:
PH: 1-800-USA-LEARN (V)
or WEB: www.ed.gov.
♪